hey guys pete here season four of fargo
ended with well
not necessarily a reveal but a big
confirmation that it told the origin
story of one of season two's favorite
characters
because it's an anthology series that
exists in the world of the 1996 coen
brothers movie of the same name
fargo fans are always on the lookout for
connections
the crossover of the characters the
different locations
and the general themes of the original
movie today i thought i'd put together
all the connections i've come across
from the movie through season 4. of
course that will contain some spoilers
if you haven't seen all the seasons
so i do have to put that out there and
now let's get into it
i thought the best way to do this would
be chronologically and since season 4
takes place in 1950
and 1951 we'll get started there if you
include ethel rita's history report we
actually go back much further in time
it's the story of the criminal
underground in kansas city and we see
how things escalate to a war between
different gangs
and at the end of the season abel
vellante with the backing of the new
york city crime families
is able to consolidate power and create
the kansas city mafia
we'll see this connection in the
evolution of the organization
as they embark on a northern expansion
the fourth season has a fargo connection
and that comes in the way of mort
kellerman lloyd cannon did
a weapons deal with the kellermans and
then called in a favor when he needed
someone from out of town to hit the fada
family for him
mort kellerman and his hitters are
directly responsible for the death of
the mother
of the then boss of the fatah family
josto
in the thought of family we were also
introduced with joe bulow who came back
from new york city with abel
beulah played a big role in the kansas
city part of the story in season two
which takes place a couple decades later
another connection between season four
and season two comes in the way of this
book the history of true crime in the
midwest
we first see this book in the opening of
season 2 episode 9.
and hear an excerpt from its chapter on
the massacre at sioux falls
this is a big event that happens in
season 2 that we were originally
introduced to back in season one in
season four we see the book in the
opening
of the ninth episode where we get a look
at a page from it that describes the
events of the upcoming episode
and i suppose it's not a direct
connection but i should mention that
since most of the
series takes place in minnesota we do
have one character in season four who's
from there
orie had a mayflower although she's sort
of a twist on that minnesota nice vibe
in that she is a serial killer here the
last major connection from season four
to season two
is that origin story i mentioned that
satchel cannon
who was loy's son did in fact grow up to
be mike milligan
who works for the kansas city mafia in
season two
satchel was part of a tradition where
the two rival families exchanged sons to
help keep the peace
rabbi milligan who was also traded more
than once as a child takes him under his
wing and they have to flee town when the
gang war escalates
rabbi dies he's taken away by a tornado
satchel makes his way back home to his
father and then sees him murdered right
in front of him
since rabbi's motivation was to give
satchel a choice
to help him avoid having to become a
child soldier which is what happened to
him and most of the other kids in this
situation
the fate that he ends up with in season
2 is cast in a different light
and so now let's move on and look at the
second season
season 2 was set in laverne minnesota
it's a small town it's near sioux falls
south dakota
with most of the events taking place in
the winter of 1979.
it focused on lou solverson who at this
point is in his early 30s
he's a cop who we've already met in his
retirement
in season one in that way season two is
a direct prequel of season one
we see his six-year-old daughter molly
who's gonna grow up to be one of the
main characters in season one i
mentioned the massacre at sioux falls we
see that play out here
and it's something that we hear the
older version of blue refer to
he talks about that in 1979 quite a bit
in his later years i mentioned the
season 4 connections and we do see a lot
of joe bulow
he heads up north to negotiate with the
gerhart family
mike milligan has chosen a life of crime
he works for the kansas city mafia he's
trying to work his way up
he plays a big role in the conflict with
the gerharts thinking that he'll one day
be running this area
in the end it turns out that he's
rewarded for his good work
with an office job working closely with
the accounting department
in this evolution of the organization
that abel volante put into motion
we saw one of his guys gail kitchen of
the kitchen brothers
in that mid credit scene that ends the
fourth season we also see how mort
kellerman's story ends in a flashback
back to 1951
in that we see that he's killed by otto
gerhart the future leader of the gerhart
family
that the kansas city mafia is up against
in this season
he's taken out not long after what
happened in season four
and the gerhart's take over since it is
a prequel we see a lot of characters
from season one
the time jump is significant enough that
they're all played by different actors
so that's kind of fun
as mentioned we see the younger lou and
molly salverson
in a dream that lou's wife betsy has
about molly's future
we see gus and greta grimley who are
part of her season one story
we see ben smith who played a role in
sioux city and all the other events that
happened in season two
and at the end we see a fight between
some kids some younger kids are getting
beat up by some older ones
this turns out to be grady numbers in
west wrench aka mr numbers and mr wrench
these two will grow up to work for the
fargo crime syndicate in season one
and with mr rent showing up here as a
child he becomes the only character to
show up in three seasons which we'll get
to
the final big connection from this
season is hanzi dent
hansi worked for the gerharts he was
taken in by them as a child
he grew up to be an absolutely effective
soldier only to eventually betray them
and go on to start his own fargo mob at
the end of season two we saw hanzi
getting a new identity
and talking about getting plastic
surgery and we'll see how
all that played out when we get to
season one chronologically the next
thing that happens in this universe
is the original film that took place in
1987
it follows a chief of police named marge
gunderson who's investigating a series
of murders near brainerd minnesota we
also meet jerry lundergaard
he's a car salesman that has money
problems he hatches a plan to have his
wife kidnapped so he hires these two out
of town criminals
and things don't go as planned as far as
the tv show there's two connections
the first would be stan grossman he was
a businessman that was a partner of the
father of the kidnap victim
he becomes successful and then in the
third season we hear him mentioned as an
acquaintance of
emmett stussy the parking lot king of
minnesota
the second connection is more direct and
it concerns a briefcase full of money
one of the hired criminals in the
kidnapping plot carl showalter
was collecting a ransom which turned out
to be a lot more money than he was
expecting
and that's all pretty complicated but
when he finds out how much more money is
there
he buries 920 000 in a suitcase in the
snow
he marks that with the red ice scraper
he basically hit it so he could cut his
partner out but then when he goes back
to their hideout they get into an
argument that ends him up in a wood
chipper
and so the knowledge of the money and
where it was dies with him
in season one we have a flashback to
1987
where the supermarket king of minnesota
stavros milos finds the money
after he runs out of gas and is stranded
on the side of the road
flash forward to the present day in
season one it takes place in 2006 and
2007
in bemidji minnesota as mentioned it
centers around the solverson family
with molly now being the same age as her
father was in season two
we see all the older versions of the
characters i mentioned
in the previous section we see that mr
numbers and mr wrench are now full grown
numbers will eventually be killed by
lauren malvo
but mr wrench makes it out of season one
alive we see the results of hanzi's
identity change
he is now running fargo under the name
moses tripoli
but he also ultimately meets his end at
the hands of lorne malvo
so the final season season three has the
shortest time skip it takes place
primarily in 2010 it features three
minnesota towns saint cloud
eden valley and eden prairie and it's
the only season that doesn't have a
direct connection to fargo north dakota
it follows the lives of the stussy
brothers rey and emmett
reyes parolee girlfriend nikki swango
for the moral center we have gloria
burgle who's a policewoman
and the big villain in this installment
is bm varga
to date none of those characters have
any connections to the other seasons
the only connection beyond that brief
mention of stan grossman from the movie
is our three season character mr wrench
i won't retell the whole story of season
three but nikki swango who i mentioned
finds herself on a prisoner transport
bus where she's targeted to be taken out
in one of the best connection reveals we
see that the person that she's sitting
next to
that she's handcuffed to is mr wrench
they're able to escape
they work together as allies in what's
arguably the best part of that season
the ending of season three and for as
far as what we know now that ends the
connections
i'm sure i missed some there's a lot of
small things like bits of dialogue that
are repeated across the seasons
but beyond that there's just so many i'm
sure i missed some so make sure you tell
me in the comments
what were your favorite connections and
which ones did you catch that i might
have missed
with that i'm going to bring this video
to a close i'm looking forward to the
future seasons
while season three isn't everyone's
favorites i would like to see some
future connections that tie that into
the bigger story
there's certainly possibilities and how
you see that might play out
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon